[Music]
do you think on the autonomous vehicle
space it's possible to solve the problem
of full autonomy without significant
investment in infrastructure well that's
really hard to speculate I think it's
not a yes/no question but how long does
it take question you know 15 years 30
years 45 years clearly with
infrastructure augmentation where
there's ro the city or whole city
planning building a new city I'm sure
that will accelerate that they of the l5
I I'm not knowledgeable enough and it's
hard to predict even one we're
knowledgeable because a lot of it is
speculative but in the u.s. I don't
think people would consider building a
new city the size of Chicago to make it
the AI slash autonomous city they're
smaller ones being built I'm aware of
that
but is infrastructure spent really
impossible for us or Western countries I
don't think so the u.s. highway system
was built was that during President
Eisenhower or Kennedy as Eisenhower yeah
so so so maybe historians can study how
the President Eisenhower get the
resources to build this massive
infrastructure that surely gave us a
tremendous amount of prosperity over the
next decade if not century
you